let's bring in Drew Brees the Saints
quarterback joining us from San Diego
did you hear about the overtime rule
true I did actually I just heard about
today what do you think well I'm not
sure what the thought process was going
into it but I would I would just run
that from what I see I would disagree
with it because you're more games are an
Indian ties now you know that that
additional five minutes especially with
the way the rules changed to where in
essence both teams get a possession
right unless somebody goes down and
scores a touchdown right away so I think
what we already saw with the new rules
of you know if a field goal can't win it
you know on the first possession I think
we saw we've seen more ties I can think
of at least three or four off the top of
my head from the last few years that are
resulted in ties based upon you know
that new rule so now make it towards
just ten minutes as opposed to 15 I
think that that that changes that
changes things you'll probably see more
ties what do you think of college
overtime rules I like it I like it I
mean it's exciting right yeah and and
and you limit you're limiting the number
of plays as well you know when you give
when you give a team the ball at the you
know 20 25 yard line and and they you
know they're already in the red zone
already in scoring position whether it's
a field goal or a touchdown then I think
you're reducing the number of plays it's
exciting for fans you know it's it's
situational football so I wouldn't be
opposed to us doing something like that
if I ask a players to vote on it how do
you think that go over if we use college
as opposed to the NFL's overtime rules
mm okay I don't know for sure but I
think I think guys would I think guys
would be fine with it especially since
overtime guys are going to be coming
from from college to the pros and it's
just the same rule you know it's just
it's just a carryover of what they've
been doing this whole time I'm not sure
what they do in high school or if it
differs between states but is this is
that that is that the rule in high
school
for a ferret I I don't know what over 10
do we Paulie do we no overtime rules
from high school
it depends by the state but a lot of
them do the college style 20-yard line
25-yard line you get the ball in each
team gets the ball so there you go if
you've been doing it since high school
and it's the same same overtime rules
and there's uniformity there then I
think that's that's something the guys
will really embrace I don't know why
they don't just dance the players but I
don't know maybe they don't want to
engage you guys I say that thing I say
that about a lot of things okay if I
said you could have input on one thing
one thing only though drew what would it
be well I think mr. disciplines try the
obvious one you got to move past that
drew a long time ago you said once it
well is it still an issue yeah it is
yes okay yeah I just don't know how Sean
Payton got docked eight million dollars
and did he in a full season yes I had a
full season and his retainers in his
reputation at the time you know which I
think a lot of people have come to
realized that that was just a big sham
you know in addition to a lot of other
things but I mean it listen it it it's
water under the bridge
it's just gone no no no no I'm just
saying I'm saying it's it hopefully it's
something that we we can all look at
recognize not only that but you know
look at when after the Patriots then
Brady look at what happened with you
know the way that the Ray Rice case was
handled and the Adrian Peterson and just
a number of others I just don't think
anybody would trust a legal ed
investigation right now
there's no credibility there there's no
transparency and so that's that's the
problem is that you know we all know
there's an agenda at play and that we
don't have a say or any type of a voice
with it we're certainly any type of
oversight so you know they're going to
do what they want to do so I'm going to
Drew Brees to the Saints would you make
of Giselle commenting on Brady's
concussions I have no comment about that
that's their business if your wife went
on the CBS Morning Show do you think
that she would your wife spill something
that maybe you wouldn't want her to
spill
oh she probably tell embarrassing like
embarrassing stories about me but not
about not health issues not helping I'll
share that with your wife if you come
home from a game and you might be dinged
or your bell rung would you tell your
wife no I wouldn't want her to worry
yeah I understand that and that's what I
thought
did you know just Brady say man I got
hit or I got a headache or I got my bell
rung and you know that difference of
that to a concussion you know maybe
there's gray area there but yeah yeah
there's that great have you had a
concussion and not known you had a
concussion well it'd be hard because if
I didn't know that I didn't know that I
didn't know that I had a no-no
eventually did drew that you have been
Riley did well I'll say this so I guess
I've had I guess I've had one documented
concussion and that was that was back in
2004 the 2004 season when I was playing
for the Chargers okay and I I mean I
obviously remember the event the hit and
everything and and I knew that something
was not right I knew it that I was
concussed but I didn't take myself out
of the game I'm I stayed in the game and
played as long as I could until finally
a coach told me I was like I'm looking
out for you here and you're not going to
play anymore because I know something's
not right and so but if it wasn't for
him I wasn't pulling myself out of the
game you know and that's why it's hard
to change that mentality for guys you
know that when you're in the heat of the
moment he to the battle and it's
competitive you do not want to pull
yourself out you know and so that's why
the concussion protocols are in place
where you need to got the I NC is the
independent neurological consultants and
the trainer's and the referees are
supposed to them and everybody's
supposed to be looking and when you see
a guy that's you know it's obviously you
know in that situation when you pull
them aside you make sure they get
evaluated before they go back out and
return to play and if it's deemed that
hey this is serious enough and you're
out until further notice which at times
I mean we've seen with Luke Kuechly and
some other guys that you know hey we'll
sit him for three or four weeks to make
sure that they are completely healed
before they go back out there and
speaking of safety a drupe
a drew drew drew is helping launch the
heat factor it's an educational program
designed to raise awareness here
explain what exertion heat stroke is so
people are at least aware of this
parents aren't sure well I think the
best the best way to think about it and
we've created an acronym with just the
term heat so H is high temperature you
know here we are approaching summertime
temperatures are going to be rising
across the the country kids are getting
out of school they're getting involved
in sports programs you know camps and
just being outside being active so so
the H high temperature II exercise or
activity a acting confused looking
disoriented maybe agitated t time to
call 911 really try to educate people
raise awareness as to the signs and
symptoms of EHS or exertional heat
stroke it's the third leading cause of
sudden death and high school athletes if
we can help you know a recent poll said
seventy percent of parents teachers
coaches would not recognize the signs or
symptoms of any HS emergency so we're
talking about something that's
life-threatening you know for kids the
more that we can be aware of it the more
we can all be educated the less likely
it is to happen and therefore we're
saving young people's lives for more
information the heat factor dot-com we
talked about this a couple of times is
that is there still height ISM in the
NFL hike ISM yeah that like like the
height of a quarterback yeah I don't
think so well I mean I think everybody
is still kind of has this image of what
you know a starting quarterback supposed
to look like you know I know there's
still the prototype I think there's
still the prototype at every position
honestly depending on what system you're
in and you know what what's that three
four outside linebacker or nose guards
supposed to look like you know but at
the end of the day it's about production
right and and it's got instincts and
it's about you know a lot of other
things that don't have anything to do
with size of shape when I look at Isaiah
Thomas of the Celtics and it feels like
he's not a franchise player to pee
because he's 5/8 if he was 6-2 then he
could be viewed as with the same stats
he would be a franchise player I feel
like that we do that you're not known as
a scrambler you're not known as a runner
you're a pocket quarterback and I think
it baffles people that you're a Hall of
Famer and you're able to do that almost
looking like well that's he's an anomaly
it just feels like we go out of our way
to label people just because they don't
fit into what we expect in certain
positions and sports I agree I think
there's a certain perception you know
that some people just can't get past you
know and and maybe that's just built
upon years and years of what they've
it's been ingrained in their minds as to
what you know talking about football
specifically like what a certain
position is supposed to look like you
know I mean Darren Sproles walks in a
room and you say there's no way this guy
just plays professional football you
know he's five foot seven and but I'm
telling you he's one of the greatest
athletes greatest like teammates
greatest work ethics like to ever suit
up you know and so you just now is he is
he is he an anomaly I mean is he is the
he's the aberration you know I mean
there's there's not many if any like him
you know but it doesn't mean they're not
out there if I saw where I think it was
Bob Griese who talked about why don't we
like quarterbacks inflate the footballs
to their liking and I've been saying
that all along you know it and not to
bring you in to deflate gate as much as
it is if I said to you you can control
what you want air pressure wise with the
football and if you're playing against
Aaron Rodgers he can do the same yeah I
don't I don't see anything wrong with
that and let's kind of give everybody a
little history lesson here so you know
back there was a period of time I
believe this 2006 prior to 2006 when you
went and played at an opposing team
Stadium you played with their ball yeah
so you didn't have your own ball you
played with the ball that was provided
by the home team and it basically there
were real limits and specifications as
to
like what that ball could look like feel
like in many cases it was basically like
fresh out of the box they did not allow
you to do much to the ball to break it
in so I remember going to certain places
like you would dread going to certain
places because like I hate the balls
they use you know and so then in 2006 I
believe it was Brady and Peyton Manning
I remember talking to Tom in and Peyton
about it basically saying hey you know
we should all be able to provide our own
footballs you know and basically break
them in a little bit to our liking and
each team provides their own balls and
we use it that way and so all the
quarterbacks in league signed a petition
and we put that in front of the league
and they approved it so that was the
beginning of everybody just being able
to provide their own football you know
and it's not like you could bring a ball
to the game that looked like it you'd
played in the Sandlot for five years
with it you know but but but you could
at least break it in a little bit so
what's the difference then now if we did
institute that rule which was they just
I mean literally you can do whatever you
want to the ball just make it to where
you know you like it you still you still
gotta you still got to throw and catch
it you know I mean it's not like it's it
makes it makes it that much more of an
advantage I mean if everybody has the
same advantage then what's the prize
it's not an advantage yeah exactly
no I agree and then you know then it's
full transparency I know you have to run
I didn't even get in an Adrian Peterson
question there but good luck with the
you're not becoming a running team all
right hey listen whatever takes
awareness whatever it's a straight if
it's like if I get to hand those two
horses and watch them run and scored
touchdowns all day then I'll be happy
with that the heat factor.com drew
thanks for joining us enjoy the summer
with the kids thank you all right thank
you I and said drew brees the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience